I don't want to say that you are an
agency chauvinist but you were just
saying that there might be one
particular way of demonstrating agency
and earlier on you were saying okay well
we should look at the overall system and
there is a distribution of agency it's
it's it has lokai all over the system
and you could draw a big boundary and
say well that thing's has agency but you
could be much more efficient and you
could draw a smaller boundary and that
smaller boundary would have almost all
of the agency of the big boundary
because most of the things in the big
boundary are just mimicking or stealing
agency from things in the small boundary
so Keith you were saying it's really
important for us to encapsulate the most
agency possible which is to say the most
amount of of temporal planning in the
smallest space imagine I'm I'm a pilot
steering a ship okay and if somebody
looking from the outside looked at the
ship they may decide that the ship as a
whole is an agent you know it's planning
like obviously it's planning it
navigated through you know the Suz canal
and some